each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I'd like to introduce Jim herb slab is
visiting today from CMU gym is one of
the foremost researchers in the social
and cognitive aspects of software
engineering and I'm really happy to have
him here telling us about his ladies
research and just as a note we won't be
using the left projector so you might
want to come to this side of it if you
if you care to see the sides so with
with that here's Jim right thank you
so here's an outline of what I want to
talk about today my research / I don't
know about the last 10 years or so has
been on things like geographically
distributed software development teams
and open source software development
trying to understand how how the
coordination on those projects were and
one of the things I've been trying to do
recently since I went to CMU about four
years ago is trying to understand more
kind of fundamental things that underlie
coordination in software engineering
which has led me to an interest in you
know fundamental things underlie
coordination and all sorts of tasks and
i'll talk more at the end about how i
think from software engineering we can
understand a lot about all sorts of
collaborative work so here's an outline
of the things i want to talk about just
the nature of task dependencies and
coordination i'll talk about a
particular way of computing what we're
calling coordination requirements who
needs to coordinate with whom to get a
particular piece of work done and I'll
talk then about some results from some
empirical work that we've done computing
coordination requirements including the
volatility of those coordination
requirements how much do they change
over time people have to coordinate with
the same people all the time or does
that change a lot then measuring
congruence how well do the coordination
behaviors of the people involved
actually match the coordination that's
required and I'll show some results that
show the effects of congruence that in
fact having coordination behaviors that
are congruent with the coordination
requirements speeds up the development
interval I'll talk about the evolution
congruence how does it develop over time
in particular i'll talk about congruence
in coordination behaviors for the top
performers because the very top
performers in the software development
project behave in much more congruent
ways than the other developers i'll show
you some data on that and finally i'll
talk about implications for tools and
for software as a service here i think
my idea is that you know software
engineering produces a very rich history
of a project just but
HR the tools that we use you know change
management version control and so on
there's a very detailed record of how
the work actually gets done most for
most tasks there is no such detailed
easily accessible record you know having
every version of every change that
everyone has done to the artifacts with
software-as-a-service I'm going to argue
you know one quick design the
functionality to create such a record
allowing all sorts of computations of
things like coordination requirements
and various collaborative capabilities
and so software engineering I see is
kind of leading the way because we've
had the data first I've had time to
think about what to do with it but I
think similar things could be done for
all sorts of tasks where the tools
appropriately designed so task
dependencies task dependencies of course
represent kind of patterns of
coordination needs you know people's
work depends on each other's work
there's research on coordination in
organizational behavior which you may or
may not be familiar with but usually in
this literature they assume that
coordination is generally generally
falls into fairly stable patterns and
they have certain you know very large
distinctions among different kinds of
coordination things like pooled now
pooled is we all just do our own work
pull the results and then you know when
we reach the end we're done sequential
I'm you know my output is your input and
so on reciprocal dependencies where my
output is your input and sometimes your
input is my output and so on but these
are all pretty simple kinds of
relationships assumed to be stable
there's also literature identifying
particular kinds of coordination
problems that exist across many
disciplines so for example we can have a
resource conflict now that can be true
of two processes running in software me
true of two people who are trying to use
the same resource and the notion here is
that there's a set of coordination
mechanisms such that you know for any
kind of coordination problem there are
certain mechanisms that help to solve it
so if
or resource contention you know we could
you scheduling for example that's one
possible way of getting around that kind
of a coordination problem so the
assumption here is that there are these
just stable types of coordination
problems and you can then select among
mechanisms that would solve those
particular kinds of problems so there's
research showing that in organizations
communication pathways going to grow up
around the most important tasks and the
coordination needs around those tasks
whose work depends on what that gives
rise to kind of communication channels
okay so in the real world dependency
patterns don't always occur in these
pure stylized forms in fact it probably
hardly ever do except for very simple
tasks for you know for hard intellectual
creative work the dependency patterns
are probably never easily characterized
by these kinds of simple patterns that
we've talked about and also it's pretty
well known that when task dependencies
change communication and coordination
may not adjust and this failure to
adjust can have dire consequences so
this next paper Henderson and Clark I
give anyone who's interested the
reference like this is a terrific paper
even though it's 16 years old they were
looking at the history of the
photolithographic alignment equipment
industry so photolithographic alignment
equipment is equipment that holds masks
on the silicon essentially or near the
silicon for the etching process and the
creation of chips and there have been a
number of generations of this kind of
equipment each one having a sort of an
architectural improvement over the
previous one in the first generation the
mask was held in contact with the chip
and the problem with this was that it
frequently scratched and damaged the
chips there was a very high reject rate
so the first improvement in this line of
work was a equipment where it was called
proximity mask it was not put right on
the silicon was just held parallel to
and very near the silicon so you know
you give up with a little resolution but
you get a much lower reject right all
right now the interesting thing for up
this is here is that that's a relatively
small change in photolithographic
alignment equipment from the contact
mask the proximity mask but it's an
architectural change in the sense that
it kind of changes the potential
interfaces among parts of the system so
for example when you have a proximity
mask anything that produces some kind of
vibration for example now as a strong
interface with the mask okay and so
designing a mask and a system for
holding the mask stable is quite
different so even though the company
which was the market leader for contact
masks was the first to introduce a
proximity mask the company never
successfully produced a really good
piece of equipment that sold well in the
marketplace they were overtaken by their
competitors and they went out of
business so what's the lesson here the
the analysis that Henderson and Clark do
of for such changes in history this
equipment where each one had a similar
result the market leader either went out
of business or became a minor player was
that the architecture of the product
gets built into the organization so that
for example of the communication
pathways become stable around the
interfaces so I know who I have to talk
to to make certain decisions and I
talked to them habitually if the
architecture changes then I suddenly
need to talk to a slightly different set
of people or more people and what
happened is people do not adjust to that
right so that that's why they never
built a decent mask also people acquire
information filters so you can't pay
attention to everything that's going on
a sizeable project you have to learn
what you can ignore and what you have to
pay attention to well if the
architecture changes that information
filter is no longer tuned correctly and
you will start ignoring or you will
continue to ignore things that you now
have to pay attention to that really
make a difference and so it was things
like this this kind of way that the
architecture gets built into the
structure of the organization that in
each case was the cause for the downfall
of the market leader at that
so in this work we kind of hypothesize
that knowledge intensive activities in
general will contain lots of
dependencies that kind of shift over
time especially in software where you
know the software of architecture the
architecture of software varies a lot
more of the architectures they have a
car right over time so we have to
continue we have to deal with this much
more in software and it seems likely
that we have lots of fine-grained
dependencies that may change quite a bit
in software as compared to other fields
and it may help design tools support
these rapidly shifting coordination
needs so if it's generally the case as
Henderson and Clark found that people
are not very good at changing their
behavior to sort of recognize these new
sets of dependencies maybe some kinds of
new kinds of tooling would help with
that
alright so now having kind of giving the
introduction of motivation for why we
care about coordination requirements
I'll talk a little bit about how we
actually measure coordination
requirements first I'll describe to sort
of in general the method and then i will
show you with some actual data how we
actually did this for a software project
so the notion is that you can use a
matrix in a very straightforward way to
represent dependencies among tasks all
right so you put in each cell a number
that represents the extent to which one
has depends on another task and this is
not real data that's why you see zeroes
along the diagonal which make absolutely
no sense but just go along with me here
so then you can also construct a matrix
it shows task assignments this is people
by tasks ok this person worked on this
task or this person did not work on this
task ok now what you get if you multiply
these two matrices is you get a task by
worker or cast by person matrix that
represents the extent to which this
person worked on tasks that share
dependencies with this task ok that's
what that matrix represents and with one
more manipulation here we multiply this
by the transpose of the task assignments
matrix we come up with a square matrix
people by people there represents the
extent to which this person works on
tasks the share dependencies where the
tasks worked on by this person ok so
this then would be sort of task
dependency matrix of the type i
described that earned sorry this is the
task dependency major this is a
coordination requirements matrix that
shows which people need to coordinate
with which other people order to get
that work done
ok I see everyone here is familiar with
basic software development tools I
probably don't need this slide here but
just talking about the kind of data that
we're going to use now to actually
construct a real one of these
coordination requirements matrices
archival data from a large software
development project this project the cup
is a small company they have one product
a 114 developers for we have almost
three years of data that are grouped
into eight teams at three different
locations so that's the data we're using
for this they had a modification request
system which is used the way
modification request systems are usually
used when people request to change the
developers if it's approved God make a
change we picked all of the
multicomponent modification requests so
we just filtered out the simple ones
that touched only one component we're
focusing only on the modification
requests where more than one component
was changed in order to implement the
request and this the tula modification
request system has as most do you know
capability for asynchronous discussions
people could just discuss the change
then we also use data from the version
control system which is you know
maintains all the changes files and the
developers also had access to and used
IRC chat various teams had chat rooms
set up which they used quite a bit watch
that's the source of the data now here's
how we constructed a coordination
requirements matrix using the data so
this is the task dependency matrix right
it's a square matrix files by files
right and in each cell we represent the
number of times two files were changed
in the same modification request okay
which we think is a good proxy for you
know all the dependencies that exists
between the stuff in those files so a
few files have changed together
frequently well you know there's
obviously some relationship between some
dependencies between
right so that's our past dependency
matrix the task assignments are which
developers modified which files right
and you can compute this for any unit
you like you can compute this for say a
particular modification request so for
one modification request certain
developers modified certain files or you
can compute it for a period of time a
week or two weeks or whatever okay so
and this is just the transpose of the
task assignment matrix and so you do
this multiplication and you come out
with again a person by person or
developer by developer matrix which
shows extent to which one developer
changed files that were related to the
files changed by another developer for
that period of time or for that
modification request okay
so that's computing coordination
requirements one of the things we are
interested in is extent to which these
are volatile how much do they change
over time in other words are people
coordinating with the same people all
the time or and our people coordinating
exclusively with people on their own
team from time to time or do they need
to coordinate with people from their own
team from other teams from time to time
so we're showing is in blue here the
Diamonds we're computing on a
week-to-week basis the extent to which
the set of people that you had to
coordinate with change from one week to
the next this is an average computed
over all the developers so if I need to
coordinate with 10 people this week and
next week one of them changes then
that's a ten percent change okay so this
is the average over all developers and
you can see this is from one release
this is from release two I believe
release three and four look very similar
release one is much lower much less
volatile much less need to coordinate
with outside people so with the but the
green is showing the squares that's what
proportion of people that I need to
coordinate with our outside of my own
team okay so what we're seeing here then
is that early on most of the
coordination is strictly within teams
you know for about the first Oh No Ken
weeks or so and then over time it starts
you start to see some churn as you know
there's the coordination requirements
begin to change it goes up to as high as
I don't know about forty percent but
it's you know substantial throughout
most of this period of time and it is
reduced again at the end and a number of
people outside the team the one needs to
coordinate with again especially in this
middle period it's highly volatile and
goes up as high as about two thirds for
the people that you need to coordinate
with are actually people who are not on
your team
so our expectation that coordination
requirements are actually pretty
volatile seems to be the case that in
software the people you need to
coordinate with week to week seems to
change quite a bit and the number of
people that you need to communicate with
on other teams also seems to be fairly
substantial alright so that's the
coordination requirements now let's talk
about comparing the coordination that's
required with the actual coordination
that happens okay so in the context of
our data we have about four different
kinds of actual coordination matrices we
can construct so one is just team
structure so people are on the same team
you know they have meetings or usually
in this case always co-located with each
other at the same site they talk to each
other you know you presume fairly often
so we can as sort of a proxy for all the
things that team members typically do to
communicate and coordinate with each
other we just note we create a matrix
representing who's on the same team okay
so there's a one there from the same
team and a 0 otherwise so that is one
form of actual coordination or proxy for
team oriented kinds of coordination
geographic locations similarly people at
the same site run into each other talk
to each other a lot more there's lots
and lots of evidence showing the
communication is far more frequent when
people are at the same site than when
they have to use the phone or email or
something so again we can represent that
as another matrix person by person
matrix use of chat so in this case we
looked at the IRC logs and people we
looked at we have actually three people
who were members of this organization
looking at the IRC logs and identifying
when a particular change request was was
noted in the log who participated in
discussion of that change request so we
can say for each change
you know whether people talk who talked
with whom about that change request in
on IRC and that's the matrix that were
that we construct here and finally we
have bug discussions online discussions
in the modification request system again
similarly you know with for each for
each change request you know who
actually participated in that discussion
that those who participated get a wand
those who didn't get a zero okay so
that's what I'm talking about when I'm
talking about actual coordination or
coordination behaviors it's these four
matrices over here that are empirical
observations that you know have nothing
to do with the way we computed the
coordination requirements
second thin team structure is that
something different work structure so
can sell a bit more out what you mean
break down the work right and
illustrating coordination like you know
you've got a scenario or something like
that here breaking it down into a list
of features so I mean that's a working
structure right right right well the
only work structure that I think that is
kind of related to this is just the
basic division of the work of designing
and developing components so it was
always the case that they assign a
development of a component to a single
team so those never you know there was
never case when they assigned a
component to multiple teams but we
aren't actually looking at you know what
the work packages or units were what
we're looking at in the results i'm
going to show you is the unit of
analysis is actually the modification
request so what we're doing is we
computed coordination requirements
matrices and actual coordination
matrices of these four kinds for all the
modification requests that touch more
than one component so that's going to be
our unit of analysis we're going to look
at that whole set of modification
request
okay so what I should have said here is
then it's it's very straightforward to
compare these two matrices and get some
measure of how close or how far apart
they are their number ways one can do
that the way we did it is to look at
every cell over here that's nonzero okay
and for each of those non zero cells we
look over here and see how many of that
set of cells is also non zero alright so
the set of cells that are nonzero over
here is showing us who ought to
coordinate with whom that's what we're
claiming and over here looking at that
subset of cells of that cells which
proportion shows actual coordination
right that's the measure we're calling
congruence the extent to which all the
coordination that should happen actually
does happen since it's a proportion it's
between zero if none of the people who
should coordinate actually do that would
be zero if all of them do then it would
be a one so it's a beber that varies
between 0 and 1
alright so now we're going to take a
look at the effects of congruence on
development speed by looking at the
amount of time it takes to actually
implement the change for the
modification request so the interview
analysis is monkey quest there's 1983 of
them's give you an idea of the size of
the data set that were implemented over
a period of about three years less than
three years so we constructed the four
measures of congruence once for each of
the four kinds of coordination behavior
that I mentioned in the previous slide
and then we constructed a regression
model all right using congruence and
some control variables as predictors
right trying to predict the resolution
time for modification request all right
so we want to see if the congruence has
significant impact on how long it takes
to do the work of resolving the
modification request
so here the regression results I just
wanted to put the flow model up there to
point out that you know you have to have
a lot of control variables to help
explain the variance and a regression
model we had a number of variables to
account for things like you know on how
many other modification requests was
this modification request dependent we
have the priority was a one through five
assigned by management how many times
was it reassigned to a different
developer because that's going to affect
the amount of time every time it's
reassigned the new person has to get up
to speed was it a customer modification
request or one that was found that
originated internally which release was
it kind of a proxy for changes that
might happen over time a team load
that's just how many modification
requests was this team working on
simultaneously divided by the size of
the team in some sense of what was how
loaded was a steam at the time the
average programming experience the set
of people who worked on it how how long
people have been in a company how much
experience they had with that component
okay so the notion is that if you've
used regression modeling you know you
really want to get a good set of control
variables to not leave a lot of variants
unexplained and so these these are just
our control variables we don't really
care that much about the outcome but it
becomes did look kind of as you would
expect for all those variables I hear
the ones that we really care about in
the model the predicta congruence
predictors and we can see that all of
them were statistically significant now
the reason we have the models are aged
like this model one is the control
variables only model two is we added in
the predictors we really care about the
congruence variables this data set has
only eight hundred nine cases because we
couldn't get the insiders to code up all
of the modification all of the chats for
all the modification requests it takes
too much time and they coded up 809 for
us randomly selected so we had a smaller
data set looking at IRC congruence we
for the full data set we have
essentially the same results except that
we didn't have the IRC coded you no one
had gone through to look for the rest of
them which bug Bay the discussions were
related to but it does confirm our our
predictions these are the essential kind
of important results that each of these
kinds of congruence helps to shorten up
the development integral and
interestingly none of them were
significantly correlated with each other
they seemed to be sort of independent
effects soooo
alright so just to summarize from our
last table a time to complete the work
item the modification request was
reduced by each of the four types of
congruence being on the same team being
at the same site chatting together with
other people involved in the work or
being involved in an online discussion
okay so another thing we want to look at
is how does congruence evolve over time
I mean are people you know instantly at
the high level of congruence or does it
get better over time to get worse over
time how does it evolve so we looked at
the data from the first floor releases
the product we can this for this data we
computed congruence on a weekly basis
and set up on a per mr basis so for each
week for that about three year period we
measured all four kinds of congruence to
see how they changed over time so the
analysis showed there was a significant
effect of time on the various measures
of congruence again we did some
statistical modeling to show that I
won't show you the whole all the details
the pattern of communication between the
top performers and other performers was
one of the more interesting things here
so here's kind of the evolution of
congruence so let me interpret this a
little bit for you so what this is you
know these are the four releases of the
product and what we're looking here is
just what was the level of congruence
for each release the average level of
congruence and we find that you start
out and geography and team structure are
very congruent so that means the work
was assigned in such a way right that
you only had dependencies with other
people on your team and at your site or
there's really no need to coordinate
with anybody else right this is kind of
what this is actually the explicit
design intent of the way the project was
set up was to assign a component each
team and hopefully you know most the
coordination will just be within teams
who won't need a lot of coordination
across chains so for the first release
that's exactly what seems to have
happened and whatever communication
there was in the bug discussions and in
IRC had no relationship to the actual
work that was going on during that
period of time was not congruent but
that was these things started to change
in released to a modification request an
IRC discussions are becoming much more
congruent than they were previously and
we're seeing that all of a sudden you
have to start coordinating with people
who are not on your team right which
wasn't true earlier by the time you get
to release three being a member the same
team isn't really telling you much about
who you have to coordinate with right a
lot of the coordination more than half
of it actually is with people on other
jeans and the use of IRC and chat
becomes highly congruent so there's
probably a lot of reasons for this one
one reasonable interpretation i think is
that you know when you start developing
the components you're building kind of
basic functionality the components and
release one and release two three and
four you're worrying more about you know
how they function together to implement
functionality there's a lot more you
know cross team and across component
kinds of dependencies and so despite you
know the best intentions to reduce the
need to communicate as much as possible
across teams and across sites of the end
up needing to communicate with people on
other teams there's also a lot of
evidence that even for something that's
architected very well at the beginning
over time you start having to make
changes that weren't precisely
anticipated by the architecture and they
tend to be more and more cross-cutting
over time that's what we seem to be
seeing here so one of the possible
conclusions of this is simply that no
matter how well you match up the
organization and the architecture of the
software that over time the match is
going to become less and less perfect
you either have to Ryoga tect you know
refactor the software or you have to
reorganize or you have to be prepared to
support collaboration you know across
teams and across
if you're going to need to do one of
those okay then some of the results that
you may have seen before have to do with
the relative productivity of different
developers there's been a lot of
research on this and there's a you know
major difference in the productivity of
the most productive and less productive
developers and we're just sort of
confirming that where this is the same
finding that everybody else has found
this looked into it but this particular
case what we're seeing is there 114
developers in this particular case 18
developers wrote half the code so it's
it varies a little bit one release to
the next these are cumulative
contribution curves where you order the
people from the person who wrote the
most codes the one who wrote the least
code and then you simply create a line
showing what proportion of the total has
been accounted for it's a cumulative
curve and so you can see that if you
average across the four releases its
right about 18 developers have written
about fifty percent of the code so we
thought it would be interesting to see
if those 18 looked any different from
the rest now here's what we see if we go
back looking at the average level of
congruence for the 18 top developers we
kind of see a pattern that looks vaguely
like the total pattern did although
things are kind of shifted upward a bit
they start out being pretty congruent in
IRC right from the beginning and the
team structure comes down as it did in
the other diagram if we look at the
other 96 developers we see that they
really never achieve very high levels of
congruence in their communication so it
starts out very low and stays pretty low
throughout so I know it's hard to know
exactly what this means but
usually when people talk about this
difference between you know highly
productive and less productive
developers it's assumed that it's some
sort of you know an eight ability that
they just write code really fast and
maybe that has a lot to do with it but
what this kind of suggests at least is
there may be kind of a social component
to this ability to be very productive
that people who really sort of
understand the system understand who is
working on what and make sure that what
they're doing fits with what somebody
else is doing maybe it's at least
something that's highly associated with
productivity we don't know what the
causal relationship is but it certainly
is highly associated with being very
productive the serve opposite of the you
know popular image of you know the nerd
sitting in the office never talking to
anybody just just hacking out code it
doesn't seem to these data seems to show
that perhaps doesn't work quite like
that and there's also other interesting
research done by people like Tom Allen
and MIT showing that the top performers
tend to have more contacts outside of
their immediate group than everybody
else this sort of fits with the picture
that's created by some of this previous
research
okay so implications for distributed
teams the coordination requirements seem
to be pretty volatile so if it is true
in software development as it seems to
be true for lots of other areas like
photolithographic alignment equipment
that the people aren't naturally and
kind of automatically aware of the
changes in coordination requirements but
it's difficult to know in full extent of
the dependencies of your current work
with other people's work then software
development is particularly particularly
difficult in that regard because of this
volatility congruence has important
effects a shortens resolution time this
really is convinced us that this is kind
of a meaningful measure because it shows
that time is reduced were congruence is
high and also the very top performers
tend to behave very congruently this is
kind of fairly convincing I think that
this congruence is a good it's a decent
measure of congruence and is something
that's important in actually getting
work done so what to say about things
like awareness tools right now for
example IM tends to have kind of self
selected buddy lists which don't change
all that much i guess they changed some
extent but now you don't change your
buddy list every week typically so if
it's if it's the fact that in work the
people who whose work depends on yours
and vice versa changes quite a bit and
people tend not to be aware of all who
those people are suggests that you want
some other kind of mechanism for
automatically noting dependencies rather
than just relying on people to try to
figure out you know who they might want
to be aware of or who they might want to
chat with or who their work effects it's
also not just the members of the same
team so something like a team chat room
isn't really going to take care of the
right you know getting the right set of
people together either so one can
imagine tools that are based on the
current set of past dependency so you
start looking at a couple of files for
example you could imagine just in the
background doing this computation
and say okay you're moving into
territory where these three people are
doing a lot of work you know before you
check something in maybe you should at
least sort of see what they're doing and
consult with them or get a quick look at
the work that you've done especially if
you see unfamiliar people there you
don't know what their role was you know
this would be a clue that gee maybe I
better you know take a look here so I'm
arguing also that this has a huge that
there's a huge potential win for
software as a service here so here's
where this kind of a leap this is a leak
towards the research area that I'm very
interested in getting into so as I
mentioned at the beginning you know you
can see now what I meant I guess when I
said that the this rich history of of
all the work and how it was done who's
involved you know what depends on what
is created sort of automatically by the
kinds of tools that we use in software
and it makes it possible to compute some
really interesting stuff about whose
work depends on on who and we could
imagine in fact even richer creating
even richer data sets by capturing more
of what people do online which is
something one of my students is working
on but uh if we were using tool as you
typically would if you know if you're
delivering software as a service where
all the data sits centrally you can put
in whatever form you want it you can
save every version of everything you
know you could note the sequence in
which people work on different documents
right so that they look at this
spreadsheet and they go to this word
document and they do something else
there's all sorts of information about
the work and how it gets done who did
what that one could capture in a bird
straightforward way that would make it
possible to do I thank all sorts of
interesting things in terms of providing
collaborative services so you'd want to
capture all versions of old documents
who changed it what was the change when
was the change made you would want
something like session data so that you
would know that you know if I'm working
on using a spreadsheet I'm using this
word processor
using this and that looking at email if
we could sort of have some sense of the
session then it would tell me that those
things are all related if I go away for
an hour come back start doing something
else then there's sort of a break and
that stuff is not necessarily related to
this stuff as sort of what a
modification request does for us in
software ok so you want some way of
understanding you know what belongs to
one task or one session that would help
to understand the dependencies so the
kinds of tools that you can hope to get
our things like a Content history so
imagine something like a great big
project proposal 400 pages of proposal
that was written by you know lots of
people over lots of time as maybe evolve
from previous proposals and so on you
can imagine having a very detailed
content history where you go ok here's
some text here's a here's a graph
showing some data where I come from ok
now I can go back and look at the
spreadsheet where that came from I know
who put it there I can go see the data
where it came from where were the data
imported from I can maybe go back and
see where the data were imported from
who gathered it I could find all sorts
of things about you know I could do sort
of archaeology of the document telling
me a lot about how much I should believe
certain things about you know how
current the data is about do I want to
just you know grab this graph and paste
it into something new or you know I
could investigate whether it's really
appropriate to do that there's all sorts
of things that would be possible I know
how to contact the person who made this
particular change to the data the change
the graph and I could ask them about it
so you can imagine all sorts of
possibilities for kind of collaboration
based on capturing that at rich sort of
data you can also imagine as as I
discuss a little bit for software you
know an awareness based on coordination
requirements based on the past history
of this set of documents if i change
this spreadsheet who's going to be
affected by that right right now that's
with different you know applications on
different computers and different files
and no history of versions you don't
know any of that stuff it's very hard to
tell comparing coordination requirements
and behavior one of the things we're
talking about
also is you can imagine in software for
example a very useful management tool
that would every week every two weeks
would compare what the coordination
requirements for this period of time who
should be coordinating with whom and
then making sure that they actually are
if they need to or maybe you could marry
it as we're starting to do we're
experimenting with constructing social
networks and because all these matrices
are basically networks represented in a
slightly different way so you can
imagine comparing putting the
coordination requirements network with
the actual communication network for
that period of time or the social
network and seeing if they're actually
congruent if the coordination
requirements change suddenly in a way
that you know people who don't know each
other have a communicative much in the
past need to communicate then as a
manager you want to step in to make sure
that's happening which could presumably
head off a lot of problems with things
like integration later on okay and
that's that's so actually looking for
application areas to work on and
collaborators I have a student who's
very anxious and move into this area and
move beyond software okay that's that's
it thank you very much a quick time for
questions
yeah so your Microsoft for example
so you talked about how
of the org chart this whole computer
mediated
very warm and very stable physical
locations where people hit of course all
the electronic flexibility to one
whereas give natural they're afraid to
break down both physical and org chart
boundaries and in the open source
community
there isn't a physical location and
there is network chart so industrial
pushes wait more toward the much more
fluid
biscuits
so
well so there's a lot of literature in
organizational behavior that suggests
that if you were designing an
organization that the stability the
environment is a crucial variable so if
you're designing an organization for a
stable environment then bureaucracy
makes an awful lot of sense so it makes
sense to have a central purchasing
department because stable environments
are always buying you know 12 inch red
widgets okay so they can take the time
and look over all the manufacturers of
12 inch requisites find the best and
cheapest deal and then put in place a
rule is it everybody buys 12 inch red
widgets over here right so
centralization makes a lot of sense when
the environment is stable when the
environments unstable you know this week
we need six inch blue widgets next week
we need something else look after we
need something else trying to have that
kind of centralization is a disaster
because the you need to shoot
information around the organization and
so on it's just overwhelms of
communication channels so decisions have
to be pushed down more locally so but to
me this is very much like the difference
between organizations building something
with a very consistent architecture
right that where things aren't you may
be evolving it but the structure stays
stable you know makes sense to make a
lot of architectural decisions centrally
then enforce them so on versus the agile
approach that may be more suited to a
very unstable environment where you have
no idea often exactly what you're going
to build you only can build little
pieces of functionality because that's
all you understand it one time and you
need to put it to place and get feedback
so I see these organizational things as
being a response to some extent
uncertainty so I think part of what
we're seeing with the coordination
requirements I would guess any real
competition of coordination requirements
has not only to do with the interfaces
and natural dependencies
the code between two components say
right if we're building two different
components that interact in certain ways
the ways that we have to interact
depends not just the nature of the way
the components interact but how certain
we are about that right so if we if an
if they interact in early complex ways
we both understand this protocol or
really really well we just build it
right but if we think they're going to
interact in simple ways but we're not
really sure we're constantly checking
back we're constantly negotiating
talking is this going to work so I can
work that's a much more difficult
coordination problem so I think the
coordination requirements this is just
sort of a start well we've got here the
many things that impact coordination
requirements beyond this and I think the
certainty is is a big part of that so
I'm not sure how you get that into
Microsoft except to make your
environment much more unstable which may
or may not actually enjoy it so it's
like this different projects you need to
try to get the the actual coordination
to try to get more congruent with the
required presentation
about thinking Microsoft more
agile or you do the other way around you
can make the required coordination less
or you can make the required
coordination match more of the actual
coordination yep so I think that route
is more interesting than that I mean to
me the real problem is that we have all
these we take about these dependencies
on other people other groups other
components and a lot of times these
dependencies have taken on but not even
realizing yeah and you don't get hired
like underneath it you know there's like
this underlying network that's being
created without our fully being aware of
that and one thing they've done a
Microsoft is that they now explicitly
check that if you try to go from one
layer the architecture to a higher later
that it flags that so even though people
aren't even even aware they're making
dependency it'll tell them you know we
don't want you to make a dependency on
in this direction but maybe we need more
tools that will tell us things like that
like you know do you realize you just
made NC on a group end you know India
that you know you it's very far away
very very coordinated sure you want to
take on that fence yeah yeah I agree so
I think so there couple things I think
are potentially important one is kind of
I think what you're sort of hinting
towards that you want to have a match
between the organization and the
architecture and understand the details
of what that ought to be what that means
I think it's important and I think tools
may have a big role to play there so the
other thing though is sort of the
question of what do you know when in
terms of time so there's a lot of kind
of religious debate between people who
are heavy process people and people who
are agile for example or people who are
heavy architecture people and people who
are agile right so they debated as if is
if it was always right either do a lot
of architecture work upfront and then
just stick to it and to do all lots of
heavy weight process stuff and then
enforce the process where's in fact I
think the appropriate point on those
continua has an awful lot to do with the
nature of the project so if you know and
are sure because you've built ten of
them before that this is the right
architecture design the architecture and
make
everybody stick to it right but if we're
building something where you know we
have some users trying to help us out
they don't really know what we want
we've never built one before we don't
have really much of a clue that's what
the architecture is going to look like
that if you go build an architecture
you're just wasting your time right so I
think that's true kind of on a process
dimension or an architecture dimension
on you know once you know what the
architecture should look like then you
can have tools that will enforce that
you know they will look over the rules
and say no you want to look at this
because we know that's not a good idea
so I think there's a couple things
operating you know the stability
environment how much you understand at
what point and you have to take an
approach that's appropriate also the
software construction having a lot of
these dependencies for I just because we
can't handle cross-cutting concerns for
better software tools mm-hmm def
30-point a tools may blair we are
playing a big role here and they'll play
more as we go along more we understand
it but i think we're talking about maybe
two different kinds one that sort of
enforces the rules when you know what
they should be and others that help you
yeah that help you coordinate with the
right people when you don't know what
the rule should be but you know who you
might screw up right but i think we need
to continue with tools as well i think
they'd be helpful in all those areas
yeah so you mentioned a few times that
people might not be aware I to know what
their formation environments are and I
guess I don't know of any evidence that
tells us whether or nothing you or
whether good ones and what better than
bad ones or how that very
organizations do you know of anything it
says there there's a big group of
developers that just don't know who they
should be talking or is it so because
not it's not a lot of evidence from
software there's there are papers in
other product development feels like the
Henderson and Clark paper I talked about
which shows that at least under some
circumstances people seem unable to find
the right set of people to talk to
particularly when there's an
architectural change and then I think at
least from this work is some evidence
showing that the top performers you know
communicate in a very congruent way and
the lesser performers communicating a
much less congruent way yeah I think
there are a few bits and pieces of
evidence I wouldn't say that it's
absolutely established at this point but
this seemed to be hints from multiple
places that was pretty tough to tell
what the full impact of some change that
you make might be especially when you
know the change has some architectural
implications yes getting presents the
bathroom
your performance report lated with my
social ability / IRC chat well we don't
know if their social and I we just know
that they were talking to the people
that we thought they should be talking
to are there any other dated points
saying what happens if you just make a
soft 14 just about dating people whether
they'll be a sufficient or do you need
the other ninety percent of the lesser
people to do local things that you know
don't require therapy that don't require
less communication more either as to
make the 18 to make the temperature feel
better about themselves and work hard
well so not from this study but there is
research that sort of looks at this so
one example would be Tom Allen again I
mentioned him earlier he did research on
what he called gatekeepers and
engineering organizations it turns out
he was interested in a question how does
new information new technical
information and techniques find its way
into an engineering organization and
this is against the background of
surveys that have been done up to that
point that shows engineers don't read
papers almost you know very the rate of
readership among engineers of papers
technical papers is very low so you know
people are going well how can that be
you know are they all just aging and
going to be no good or how the new ideas
ever come in this just this a terrible
situation you know maybe we're going to
lash them into reading more papers but
he sort of looked at how information
actually flows and engineering
organizations and it turns out there's
sort of a small number of people that he
called gatekeepers other read lots of
papers actually and they write papers
they go to conferences and they have
contacts outside of their own group both
outside the company and in other groups
in the company and the way information
typically flows is when people you know
when these gatekeepers find out new
things that are relevant they go show
people and talk to him about it you know
when people have questions about gee I
wonder is a new newer technique for
doing this they would come to the
gatekeeper who uses his knowledge of
richer to help answer the questions the
other thing that was interesting is when
you look at the social networks of
people the gatekeepers are almost always
in the same network most of them anyway
so not only do they bring in information
pronounced lie but I talk to each other
so it seems to be the case that they're
like the nervous system if you will you
know for new information getting into
and circulating around the company so
they not only are aware externally of
more people and more ideas but they also
know what the other gatekeepers know and
what they keep up with and so they can
provide a you know one source to access
lots of information inside the company
so one guess or one interpretation we
don't really know these people are also
gatekeepers and by the way the
gatekeepers also were technically highly
regarded people and very productive as
well but one one possibility might be
we've just found the gatekeepers here
and that people just communicate with
them for particularly relevant kinds of
problems and they you know supply
answers we don't know who's initiating
the communication could be they are
asking questions or disseminating we
haven't looked at that but that so there
are suggestions about the relationship
of these people and everybody else that
but they all you know work together get
the work done but this information
dissemination functions needs to be
handled by these communities of
gatekeepers
yeah from the global companies such as
for example service providers others
that have a global substantiate across
the world then
so I studied so I spent about six years
in Bell Labs so I studied lots of
development groups that listen and since
I've been CMU I've studied development
groups and several other companies but
we haven't done this exact study with
any company except for this one we're
trying now to get data to replicate it
and a few other places but but that's it
for a moment yeah and you have any
insight data a coordination of these
place between developers and lichens on
developer rules too late between
developers and testers yeah you know
that's a great question and we don't
have any data for that I'd like to and
we plan to sort of expand this beyond
just the development group so this this
is sort of an initial cut looking just a
coding but there's all sorts of
dependencies on design and requirements
and marketing and product management
sand you know maybe even customers and
testers and all sorts of things that are
probably equally important but this is
the data we had access to this as far as
we've gotten at the moment ears hear
further these tools ideas content is
today as I given sessions even
would start to capture that I love them
so maybe see some relationships between
documents native code you have to pick
up and not use that yep one of the
things one of my students is working in
a project where he is a building a
eclipse plugin the first step to the
project is building an eclipse plugin
that captures very detailed data about
everything a developer does that could
be captured in that environment so every
file it's opened and where and file they
look and if the scrolling around in the
file and opening a web page looking at
documentation everything that the
developer does that can be captured
pretty much he's capturing and the idea
then is to use that to sort of create a
history for every change so the notion
is I could look if I wonder why does
this function look this way I would
expect to look some other way I can sort
of click on that and it would pull up
sort of replay of everything that
happened up to that change that this
developer did what documents they looked
at what files I had open where they were
looking in those files then finally the
edit and hopefully from that kind of
recreation that replay I could figure
out you know why it looks the way it
does so I guess yeah I think you're
right that that we should be looking for
more ways to use data that exists I
think we can also you know start
capturing more and there's an awful lot
that could be recorded if we designed
our environments to do that and I think
a lot of it would be so hopefully I will
sort it out something probably won't be
but we'd find ways of capturing it and
then ways of filtering it and displaying
it so that you can actually get
something out
these are the club's jokey sorry
yeah released three and release for each
other hundreds org chart and you
suggested that you thought that there
could have been a better workshop is
that true that there could that there's
an optimal bar chart given the
communication that is happening on this
group or is it really than that the
network has gone scale-free mm big
question yeah I don't know that's
something we should look at though that
seems like you're saying that the top
mm-hmm right yeah so it could be so so
yeah if we have this sort of Tom Allen
like gatekeeper structure then like what
you said is true and your suggestion
that there is no great perfect org chart
is also true that just have to get used
to the idea that the thing is a big
network and it takes its own shape and
you don't want to take all the
gatekeepers and separate them you know
so communicate with anywhere that would
be just stupid so it may well be that we
need to think about organizational
structure not as an alt chart but as a
network maybe that's maybe the org chart
and the tree or the graph or whatever is
well the tree is just the wrong model
and even a matrix one may not be
interlinked enough so I don't know how
you adjust sort of authority and
responsibilities and so on in a network
purely network structure but it
certainly scenes that based on previous
work that that's likely what we would
find we plan to do that analysis so it's
the same question you could ask about
the volatility question so so if my
volatility is ten twenty percent for
several weeks in a row does that mean
that there's just say a few people are
flipping in and out in the same people
over and over again which we show up as
volatility or is that these two people
no different to people no different to
people no different to people we haven't
looked at that I don't know which does
it is so there's more to be done there I
suspect this kind of a network looking
thing and I don't I suspect probably
can't have a good Archer well is it a
network that has local connectivity
that scale-free where you have separates
that are doing like a small little live
events yeah well my guess would be so
the the gatekeeper networks you would
expect are kind of small world cup
networks right which have high
clustering but also short average
distance right so those are the two
characteristics of together and make
kind of a small world network so that
I'm tightly linked to my group and we're
separate from other groups but there are
enough random links among clusters that
the average path between any two people
is short that's what this gatekeeper
since they talk to each other they
create these links you know among
clusters that's the sort of network they
would produce I suspect we find the same
here but again it's something we haven't
looked at yet but I imagine that's how
it works small world kind of thing
so what about the geographical
information about the coffee where they
were yeah what structure dimension yeah
that's true so you see that for both
them geography remains you know kind of
high in congruence in other words that
they usually just have to coordinate
with people at growth site but often
with people on other teams so uses that
would lead me to suspect the software is
kind of hierarchically structured but
the components are somewhat separate
from each other but they're more closely
related components developed at the same
site and less related to components of
other sites because it doesn't seem to
be this cross site congruence happening
but it could be the cause could be the
other way to that they realize well
we'll never be able to coordinate across
sites are gonna you know we're not going
to do that we're going to have some
separation of things but yeah I don't
know where the high performers word I
know they were not all at one site they
were spread around to some degree but
I'm not sure how evenly yeah
there were questions
well attention one more time